let's get right into things today
because we have so much to discuss i'm
not going to waste 10 minutes with a
meta segment telling you what's going to
be on today's show i mean this is the
show let's just do the show right that's
my perspective
i told you yesterday that today we would
talk about
a sort of new it's almost like an
anti-consensus the increasingly the
consensus from scientists about
covid and the trajectory of this
pandemic is
the end is uncertain we don't actually
know and you'll still hear
some individual public health experts
and epidemiologists and others say
if we do x we'll probably be mostly back
to normal by some date but at this point
it should be pretty clear to most of us
that it's not clear when this is going
to end and that the ifs that are often
referred to if we get to this level of
vaccination
if there is no more contagious or
dangerous variant if this these are ifs
over which
we really have very little information
and it's a significantly unclear so i
want to start here
um with an article that outlines this
for scientists path to covet end game
remains uncertain this is for by mark
fischer from the washington post from
this weekend it's basically over already
it will end this october or maybe it
won't be over till next spring or late
next year or two or three years down the
road
from the most respected epidemiologists
to public health experts who have
navigated past disease panics from
polemicists to political partisans or
partisans as some like to say there are
no definitive answers to the central
question in american life as a drudge
report headline put it recently is it
ever going to end with children
returning to classrooms in many cases
for the first time in 18 months and as
the highly contagious delta variant and
spotty vaccination uptake send case
numbers and death shooting upward many
americans wonder what exactly has to
happen before life can return to
something that looks and feels like 2019
the article rightly uh pointing out the
answers come in a kaleidoscopic
cavalcade of scenarios some suggested
with utmost humility others with
mathematical confidence the pandemic
will end because deaths finally drop to
about the same level we're accustomed to
seeing from the flu each year or it will
end when most kids are vaccinated or it
will end because americans are finally
exhausted by all the restrictions on
daily life
innumerable predictions over the course
of the pandemic have come up lame some
scientists have sworn off sooth saying
but as they learn more about the
coronavirus that bestowed or bestowed
covet 19 on mankind they build models
and make projections and describe the
hurdles that remain before people can
pull their masks pull off the masks and
go about their lives the good news is
there is some fuel from for optimism and
i think that
i think that this is accurate in terms
of the possibilities of optimism let's
look at what it says
i truly truly think we are in the
endgame says monica gandhi
an infectious disease specialist the
cases will start plummeting in mid to
late september and by mid-october we
will be in a manageable place where the
virus is a concern for health
professionals but not really for the
general public that is very optimistic
but we are seeing
if you expect cases to be much lower in
october the leveling off we've seen over
the last seven days
suggests that that's a possibility
gandhi bases our optimism on the fact
that all previous epidemics of
respiratory viruses have ended through
the acquisition of immunity whether
vaccination or natural infection
although viruses do keep changing
potentially circumventing people's
defenses they mutate quickly at a cost
to themselves weakening over time our
guest vincent raqueniello last week from
the this week in virology podcast said
the same in terms of the mutating to be
less serious gandhi said she believes
the delta variant that has hit the u.s
so hard this summer will mark the peak
of the virus strength but
gandhi warns she has been wrong before
in february 20 she said the u.s would
not tolerate a disease that killed 100
americans a day people would come
together and do whatever it takes to
stop that that didn't happen the bad
news is there is too much cause for
doubt
zeke emanuel professor of medical ethics
at upenn we're in a moment of
uncertainty and humans don't do well
with uncertainty telling people it's
going to be two or three more years of
this is really hard but i don't think
anyone can be comfortable with the
current state with a lot of kids ending
up in the hospital and a thousand deaths
a day that's not
returning to normal and emanuel also
says his crystal ball has sometimes been
cloudy in march of 20 he said the
country would be back to normal in
november of 21.
for that his friends dubbed him mr
pessimist now his message is at least as
unwelcome it's going to be at least
spring 22 and possibly much longer
before things go back to normal so at
this point this is as much a
psychological question
of what does it do to society
to be living with this for
we don't know how much longer now that
psychological pressure
has pushed some who never took it super
seriously to just say we're back to
normal either i'm vaccinated and we're
back to normal or
i'm not vaccinated and i never thought
we needed vaccines or to do anything and
i'm going to continue in that way but
when you look at the case and death
numbers tomorrow i'm going to actually
show you
cases are three times higher than a year
ago
deaths are two times higher than a year
ago that doesn't feel like it's almost
over
but at the same time you've got some
points of optimism there are some
studies that show that uh an
overwhelming majority 80 even more
percent of some some populations in some
cities have some degree of antibodies
which would be due to a combination of
infection vaccination people who never
knew they had asymptomatic cases etc so
do what what is the point of this do we
really know anything no yes maybe i
don't know we do know some things
we know that this mutates slowly enough
that when you start getting to these
higher levels of immunity
you may not do away with cases
but cases won't mean nearly as much
because it will mostly mean colds and
for the vaccinated population
that's sort of already the case i mean
when you read 1500 vaccinated people
have died it's hard to feel like that
means if you're vaccinated this no
longer matters but in the grand scheme
of the numbers that's a quite small
number
people die of the flu even when
vaccinated etc
so the last part of this is
how do we define the end are we
comfortable saying the end is
when the death numbers are the same as a
normal flu season is that the end has
this so traumatized us that even that
won't really signify the end will it be
where anyone of any age who wants to get
vaccinated can be vaccinated which could
be some time until young kids can get
vaccinated that's another piece of this
which is how do we define the end the
next thing i want to talk about is this
mu variant mu which many of you have
been emailing me about